hey guys Pete peppers here with the
commentary walkthrough for the dreaded
candy crush jelly saga level 171 it's
the licorice Larry level and it is the
worst sometime to play it a lot so that
I could give you guys some some useful
insights because like I said it is
really tough it's the one that took the
worst or the longest amount for me to
get through this last bunch and the good
news is is there is a better strategy
you can try to apply as you go and I'm
gonna play through it here and stop when
I need to so that I can talk about the
important things so in the beginning
we're gonna make some specials with
orange we do need to clear out those
licorice links but it's it's not we
don't really want to waste a lot of
moves doing it necessarily just you can
see in that cascade there things happen
anyway so we'll just keep that in mind
as we go I do want to make specials like
I said and color bombs that'll attack
our color or great the obviously you get
all the ones that are on the board at
the time but what we're really trying to
do is we're trying to work on the bottom
half for the most part and then we're
really trying to catch it there's so
many orange you have to get we're trying
to get them in cascade so kind of like
the primary primary thing to do is to
get all of the I'm gonna hold it here
get all the candies to fall so that we
can get a ton of orange collected as
they do so anything that anything that
gets things moving around is good this
is an important this is an important
move here that I'm going to talk about
and what but one thing about here is
that you know you when you're doing this
at least for me when I was playing it I
would I can get like where I'm only
thinking about that orange candies and
that's not going to be the best way to
collect them like if you
just matching them you'll never get what
you need so here we have a situation
where a yellow coloring candy fell in
it's sitting above a wrapped candy and
you know I spent some time looking
around here but really you know we can
actually match this wrapped in this
coloring candy together by making it
fish with the red and just keep an eye
on how much orange we pick up as a
result of doing that because it's gonna
clear out the board and stuffs gonna be
going everywhere so this is a great
example of how to collect a lot of
orange fast without using orange in the
first place so at this point we have 18
moves left which is is good that's when
you pretty much want to get your first
monk Ling on the board and what's what I
found the most frustrating about this I
mean this is great you know look at all
this stuff I'm collecting even though it
was at the end and I didn't need that
much when I found that that can be
really frustrating is then you get to
this point where there's just nothing
really good on the board and it happens
over and over again like yeah we can
collect our monk link here which is
fairly useless because it's gonna happen
anyways and you know I made I made a
striped over there hoping to get me you
know get my stun up so that I could I'm
gonna pause it again get my stun up so
that I could clear out some space and
you know get that thing moving but um
yeah there's just a couple of moves and
it gets stressful the more the less
moves you have left the more stressful
gets in that you just can't really
collect much of anything or do much of
anything so try to keep your cool
whenever that happens I mean it's just
gonna happen sometimes so another thing
that drives me nuts is that even though
I all the times I've played this and I
think I've probably played it hundred
over a hundred you know hundreds at this
point liqueur licorice Larry has never
finished you know I've never lost
because he won
he has as much trouble as I do in
getting it and here's another example
real quick as you know what we can clear
we're making a match that doesn't have
making do with orange but it's gonna
collect a ton of orange see all that but
yeah so even though he can't he can't do
anything the way that his programming is
is you know he's pretty simple and and
he'll block a lot of times and that was
driving me nuts when I was playing this
it's like I don't you know it's really
hard to ascertain what he's blocking
from because he's not gonna win anyways
but I guess the way the dynamic is he
doesn't have to win he can as long as he
just doesn't lose so that can be really
frustrating too so this is uh this is
one of those spots you know there's lots
of different choices what are the best
ones I think here you know you make this
stripe to the top with the intention of
we've we made the specials now so we
have a stun so now we can actually just
match this yellow and it's gonna it's
also going to set off that raft which is
gonna cascade down and set up more stuff
so it's a good moving down the board
kind of situation and here I like making
the color bomb first we're not gonna
probably be able to match them together
as you can see but another thing to
think about these coloring candies and
I'll pause it again is that whenever you
make a match that directly makes a
special you're gonna get another turn
it's gonna step it's gonna stun Larry
and one another thing I want to point
about this and why I held it is I before
like whenever the egg is almost all the
way full I found myself wanting to hold
on to this coloring candy until I filled
filled it up and then use it so that I
could get like another quick fill up I
would recommend against doing that you
know you just can't playing out that
that with that much detail and this
because you you run out of moves that's
what happens is you always run out of
moves you don't like I said licorice
Larry never wins you never have to worry
about
blocking him and so you know don't get
too fancy just go ahead and make them
the most effective move at the time so
think about what you would do right here
like I said if we can make a special
then we will get another move which
would be key in having this color color
bomb already on there and we weren't
able to do it there but it will come in
handy or it will come into play in a
later one so just keep in mind about
that so here I'm just I'm just like
moving things down stacking up special
stunning stunning layering the move on
the making matching these two stripes
together at the bottom gonna be a move
that we're gonna make I'm just sort of
looking around for something that I can
do first and here I'll set up another
there you go and this is a good this
combo is a good combo or just the
stripes good combo just because for the
same reason you know it gets everything
moving across you can see you know other
stripe other stripes and things that we
set up or
or moving around and now we can just go
ahead and set this off get a nice stun
and things will fall for us so we got
extra fortunate that we got another
orange color in candy that won't happen
regularly you know that it's random how
they fall there's no way to influence
what falls but this is an important this
is an important thing here because we're
not that close even though that looks
like it's pretty cool we're not that
close yet and we only have three moves
so what's important about three moves is
is that we have to fill it up with one
left in order to drop the monk link to
the ground or you know below the string
so
when you get like this you know you
definitely want to take your time and
figure out you know what's gonna what's
gonna actually displace the most amount
of candy so that you're collecting as
many as you can because if you if you
get the marketing on the board zero
moves left there's no way to collect
them so you'll see I'm taking my time to
think about this I'm kind of looking up
there but I realized that I could make
that striped and that it's obviously a
great situation and because I did that I
get another move so this is you know
this is going to get the monk lling on
the board and all now that we need is to
hope that there's a match underneath so
that we can collect them and as you can
see it's set up so we did so it's a it's
a really tough level
hang in there take breaks if you got to
the tips are like I have mentioned as we
went along here you want to clear out
the board with big moves they're gonna
they're gonna pick up oranges in in
Cascades in general you want to work
towards the bottom of the board but you
look all around it a hundred percent
look for matches that are gonna lead to
other big action events you know don't
don't you know if you see a match three
with orange try to look around the board
and find something that'll do a little
bit more because you know you want to
make specials you want to stun Larry you
want to think about that when you get
your super stun move of where you're
gonna best clear out some space and get
things to move around and you want to
look for making specials that you can
use in combos that even if they don't
involve the orange candies they're gonna
do that you know they're gonna clear out
big parts of the board and take lots of
orange candies into collection as the
things are moving down so hang in there
hope this helps please give it a like I
try to make these kind of tips
videos for the most complicated and hard
levels and I appreciate your support
make sure you subscribe to my channel so
you could keep up to date with all the
latest thanks